hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's video you know
today is uh Wednesday October 12th 2022
and you know the subject of today's uh
video is on trap Traders and and that's
a term that really gets abused a lot and
I think is really misinterpreted to mean
something else really what the term I
prefer is you know stuck Traders or
Traders caught offsides which is really
what's happening and you know sometimes
it's hard to see on a on a regular chart
and I've seen people you know show bar
charts and say oh there's trap Traders
here at this High I mean you're just
guessing you know really what is a trap
Trader well it's a Trader that's long
and wrong or short in the hole and
you know unless you're looking at the
volume honestly I don't understand how
people can say oh there's traders that
were trapped up here because you don't
know if you know what traded at a high
was um small volume you know it could
have just been one or two contracts
traded up here at a high you know for
example let's uh let's just go back a
little bit here right people you know
down here right Market broke out here
took out this low traded nine contracts
you know people say oh there's prep
Traders down there no you know it traded
nine contracts okay even if those
Traders were trapped it's only nine Lots
right that could be you or me you know
our position
um you know especially on a bar where
you're trading you know forty four
thousand contracts and you got a volume
of nine you know over here you got two
you know people they they see the the
market poke up or poke down and think
automatically oh there's trap Traders
there you know um you know the the big
money sprung a trap it's all just
nonsense really really what it is is is
Traders that are caught offsides
generally speaking at a high or a low
but it could even happen in moves and
I'm going to give you some examples here
today you know in the S PS this is the
e-minis
um this is a 30 second chart people say
wow that's such a fast chart no it's not
really you know 30 seconds is
the new one minute chart I think in my
opinion but you can see here this red
candle up right you're sort of coming up
to the swing High 36 uh 16 16 and a
quarter right here and you have this
buying and balance here okay now
remember I spent a lot of time uh
recently talking about imbalances you
know imbalances occur in the two as a
result of the two-way auction when
there's more aggressive trading to one
side and
that alone is sort of the first step to
recognizing you know traders that are
offsides because if you have an
imbalance at a high and the market comes
off of it
what do you think the trade is going to
be we think we're going to come back up
there no most likely not I mean
eventually you know the market may come
up there but really in the order flow
order flow makes it so easy to see when
Traders are offsides and actually I have
a term for this that I've coined many
years ago it's called an inverse
imbalance and you know a stacked
imbalance which is what most order flow
Traders are used to looking for in the
market is
um you know a stacked buying imbalance
would be three or more buying imbalances
stacked in a bar or stacked style in a
balance like this right here in this bar
the 108 the 25 to 74. this is a stack
selling to balance the next part got
another stack selling a balance
um
there is you know here's a stacked
buying imbalance right in green candles
you expect to see
the aggressive buying right I mean
that's normal right Market's going up
you're seeing aggressive buying just as
you know markets going down you see
selling the bounces right I mean
aggressive Traders are present they're
selling the market down they're hitting
all the bids the next bid and the next
bid but what about when you're sort of
up here at this swing High you got the
aggressive Traders again you know
remember you know when you're looking at
a bar
the bar is not complete until you know
the conditions are met you know in what
I mean by that is you know if you're
looking at a 30 second bar it's got to
do the full 30 seconds right because
early this bar is is quite
um bullish right you see that buying and
balance up here the 58 the 113 you know
even down here the 118 but then you know
conditions change for whatever reason
okay you know as order flow Traders we
don't really care the reason why it's
changed what we care about is that it's
changed okay so what's happened is early
in this bar you got very aggressive
buying but something happened something
changed then you got aggressive selling
so you got aggressive buying on the top
half of this red candle aggressive
selling on the bottom half of this green
of this red candle
all right so I mean you expect to see
aggressive selling in a red candle right
that's normal but you don't normally see
aggressive buying at the top especially
coming in at a swing High here at 16 and
a quarter and then it just reversed
right so you know the easiest way to see
these traders that are caught off size
and you know offsides is a is a soccer
term or sorry you know a football term
um you know where the ball is kicked
or sorry where the players you know the
the other teams players up near the goal
before the ball is kicked right that's
offsides it's just like what's happening
here is you know Traders are jumping
over themselves fomoing into this Market
and then yeah I know I think the rug
gets pulled but you know what conditions
change and the market gets whacked right
and it sells off now if you're looking
at a footprint it's pretty easy to see
right all you gotta do is just simply
look for these red candles and these
buying imbalances up there okay but
again you know it's not something that
happens all the time and you know in our
order for those Trader software we
actually have a function in here we call
it the inverse imbalance setting because
basically what it is it's the opposite
of what you would expect to happen right
with the stack of buying imbalance you
expect the market to go up but it's
actually doing the opposite right this
is what it is inverse imbalance now I
have it turned off on this chart this is
just my plain footprint chart for all
you guys that just use a plain footprint
chart but on the order flow Trader
software right you can see it just
sticks out right up here like a sore
thumb
I mean it doesn't get any more obvious
than this right here this big you know
you can even draw out the Zone
um this you know this overhead
resistance I mean look at that you know
Market just sold right off you came down
here you had an inverse imbalance of
buying one
already went up a little bit so imagine
if you're short from up here around the
14 area you know down to the 3600 it's a
14 point move okay you may get long in
here now you get stopped out fine you
know you just had a 10 point you know 14
point winner and then you just you know
took a two-point loser here but again
this is not something that happens every
day in the market some days you know
more volatile days it probably happens a
bit more than than normal conditions I
don't think there was anything yesterday
but it happens you know in plenty of
other markets here's the euro currency
today this was a nice one you know
Market sort of worked its way up started
coming off you've seen some aggressive
buying coming in here but what's it
running into it's running into Supply
but these Traders you know they're you
know Market went up uh is my opportunity
to buy the dip right ptfd
buy the dip
but it's met with Supply
and the market drops further you know
this is from you know the 97 what is
this 9740 ish area
all right right in here you could have
gotten short somewhere in here 38 even
heck it's called 36 because there's a
lot of volume went through here at 37
36. you know all the way right straight
down to you know 97 15 97 16. actually
the market did recover come back up
there but for now these Traders were
caught offsides you know gold you know
this is a nice one in the gold this
morning euro currency one came in at you
know 936 the e-mini one came in what
time was that at uh you know just up to
1 30. gold there was a nice one here and
um you know some of these commodity
markets Sometimes you seem to get a bit
more like uh gold it's a nice one here
in the gold
this one came in at 8 34. so you know
they're coming in at different times I
think gold had
a couple
uh must have been earlier
in the morning
um
no but you see yesterday right yesterday
not really anything here there was one
where was it here I just saw it
um you know the small little one here
right around 10 30. yeah you know I
prefer them to come in at swing highs
rather than you know as the market is
moving but generally you know people ask
you know what's going to be more
effective well ideally you know what you
want to have if you're thinking of
offsides in the purest sense
it's when it appears at a swing high or
swing low or just off a swing high or
swing low you know I mean again I would
have given this one
um some serious consideration if the
market started moving down didn't start
moving down until about five minutes
later when you have
um you know offsides you want it to be
confirmed pretty quick right
right here right in the next bar
confirmed it right and by confirmation
what I mean is you know the markets to
start moving away from that level sooner
rather than later
now in like I said like markets are a
bit more volatile M and Q you're going
to see more
okay now again if depending on what your
settings are you know how you want to
identify one
um you know for me I like there to be at
least two
stacked imbalances on more volatile
markets you know
mnq you know maybe you want to make it a
little bit bigger three but again it's
up to you do your own analysis basically
you know this is a two level one here
all right this one came about three 2 30
in the afternoon started moving up
pulled back a bit towards that level and
then just skyrocketed it up right you
know we're talking a move from
you know you'd be getting long so I
don't know 65 66 you know it just shot
straight up into the 80s
um you know going into the cash close a
bit earlier you know those are short
here another short here a couple Longs
um you know this is a nice one market
sold off pulled back up towards that
level and then
sold off you know here's some Buys so
it's a nice sell up in here but again
you know on a market like M and Q you'd
probably want to use a stronger setting
of like three imbalances as opposed to
just two because you know two you you
know on a volatile Market getting two is
fairly
um
fairly often I guess is the term I would
use as opposed to a market like e-minis
right because you know the volatility in
the mnq is much more than you're seeing
in the
um e-minis okay and even this is much
more than you're seeing in gold right so
you know a level of two might not be
strong enough on the chart that you're
trading you know people also ask you
know can you use this on
um a longer term chart well you could
but generally you know stacked
imbalances don't last that long when you
start going up on higher time frames
like on a five minute chart or something
like that you know for example okay so
this is
um
well this is my euro currency all right
let's just change this
to a
you know I don't know what Market well
bonds you really you know I'm kind of
curious what bonds are going to look
like I doubt you're really going to get
much
in the bonds if anything because you
know it trades a lot generally speaking
it trades a lot of volume doesn't have
that same
volatility that you have in the um
in the equity markets but I mean
nevertheless let's let's pull up a chart
and see how it looks here we go
yeah
I'm not seeing any
I'm just I was just curious to see if
there would be any
I mean you never know what these things
yeah I mean you just don't see it in in
certain markets just because you know
the way that they trade
um so again you know it's not something
that you can see in every Market but you
know if if you
you know
I'm gonna say adjust your chart type but
you know treasuries I like looking at
you know on a four range chart and you
know the reason for that is you know
trades into their house hey I don't have
any big scientific reason other than a
trades in 30 seconds but um you know
I've always looked at uh Bonds on a
on that sort of time frame
um yeah
I think but again what I have the
settings set at if I were to actually
change the setting
from
you know because I'm on a
four range chart okay so getting
a stacked imbalance on a four range
chart is hard enough and getting the
inverse imbalance
is going to be even harder so let's
shift it let's change it to one
okay because what this would mean now is
not necessarily that Traders are off
size but it's generally meaning that
they're supportive buying or resistant
selling coming into the markets right
you can see right here right right here
now when you have it set at one in a
thicker market like interest rates it
it's it's still Traders caught off sides
because you know what's happening is you
know Traders are they're buying this
offer right it's a strong offer it's
causing an imbalance and this sort of
follows up on the
um discussions that I had yesterday but
you know you can see right here right
it's giving you some very strong
um
directional signals especially one that
imbalance isn't tested in the next bar
now again I wouldn't use one on a market
like e-minis or definitely not NASDAQ
because you only get a lot of inverse
imbalances but on these thicker markets
I mean look at this right look at that
it's
you know Traders you know sometimes I
don't know you know I see a lot of
videos people post on Finn twits you
know Twitter and
gosh even on Facebook and stuff and
they're really trying to get very
complex they don't need to get so
complex okay but what does it mean when
I have a buying imbalance in a red bar
what does that mean it's very simple
right it means you have Supply coming
into the market just as what does it
mean when I've got a selling a balance
coming in on on a green bar generally it
means they're supportive buying coming
in
simple right and we don't make trading
more complicated than it needs to be
all right guys anyway I'll end it there
um you know hopefully you're coming away
with some information and again you know
it's
looking at a normal footprint like this
yeah you can see it right but you kind
of know what to look for you know this
is why we created our I created my own
software to help me in my own trading
and you know we just released the newest
version overflow Trader six and this is
just one of the tools in there
um you know to help Traders I mean if
you're just using this one tool to take
these trades you know what what would
that mean you know do your trading
results I mean you can see how how nice
these trades look
right I mean yeah you have some that
don't work out like this one but fine
you've got some that work out quite
nicely
you know here here
so anyway guys you know I'm just
probably preaching to the choir you know
I get excited when I see stuff like this
on on a chart that just stands out so
easily so anyway guys if you enjoyed
this video be sure to like And subscribe
you know like the video subscribe to the
channel
um you know I enjoy making these videos
it sort of reinforces you know my
followers
um you know what I look for in the
market and what you can start to look
for in the market as well so anyway guys
have a great day talk to you tomorrow
bye-bye